hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another video today I'm going to talk
about using split testing as a way to
improve the effectiveness of your
marketing campaigns and specifically to
get more people to sign up for your
newsletter so this is the page that I
showcase all the favorite tools that I
use to grow my business and what I use
to my newsletter is a service called
Aweber just find it here and so my list
is over 50,000 people kind of growing
every day and I'm gonna log into my
Aweber back-end and show you how I'm
using a number of different tests to try
to get the most out of my email list so
front of you who are trying to get
people to sign up for your email list
split testing is a fantastic way to do
it and be able to get the most are the
people who are visiting your site so
this is the Aweber backend and these are
the different web forms you can create
so the test that i recently set up is
around the lightbox in a lightbox is one
of those hover things that pop up over
your page when somebody logs on to your
site so a quick example if I load one up
just so you can see what it looks like
is this so you basically give away a
free offer so it's a free ebook that has
a value on it people can enter their
name and email you can show some other
things here as well and then they sign
up and they get the email so this kind
of hovers over the page and they can
either fill it in or close it so I
recently set this up I'm not committed
to the lightbox idea i just wanted to
test it out a few friends of mine had
some good success with it so like any
marketing you test it out and see if it
works you or not and so I set up eight
different tests and I can do it because
I get significant traffic to my site so
for you you might want to just test one
thing at a time and you know make sure
you have something that works before
moving on you'd want to run too many
tests because and it's hard to determine
which one is actually going to generate
a good result for you or not so for me
in his example the different things that
I tested I'll load that one back up here
I haven't tested the offer and so that's
something that you can test as well and
what is the offer and you know what's
the best one to give people that they're
going to have the best response with I
do a lot of stuff from famous
entrepreneur so that's how I started off
what I'm testing that I'll show you some
data on one is is it better to have
people leave their name and email or do
I want to give them the option to log in
via facebook now Aweber allows you to
integrate facebook into your forms so
somebody has logged in through facebook
you can see that they can quickly log in
and sign up through the facebook account
i want to test adding media in here so
it shows that hey this is reputable site
it's been featured in lots of different
media before and i want to test if
there's a customer testimony or not so
in this testimonial one of my newsletter
readers it's a success story you know
you have no idea how much your stories
have saved my life on say thanks and so
I wanted to test having Facebook or
having your name and email having the
media in or not and having a testimonial
in or not so all in all it creates eight
different scenarios that i can highlight
here so you can see the difference now a
lot of them have gotten some some good
impressions so we're looking at you know
25,000 of thirty thousand impressions
each so we're getting some decent volume
on that will make some numbers from and
you can see they've had a big difference
one example is our best one performs at
one point five percent so one of the
half percent of people who saw it
convert it to become a newsletter
subscriber and the worst one converted
at point five percent so there's not
that much different i spent a lot of
time making that ebook and crafting the
message that's where most of the work
was the only difference is those few
elements like facebook or not you know
do i put a picture just a couple
pictures into testimonials or meeting or
not and just try making a few tweaks i
can go from point five to one point five
percent and i can triple the amount of
people who subscribe to my newsletter so
you're taking all that work and you're
just getting more and more out of it so
this is the value of testing because
there isn't that big a difference
between my three scenarios
so the one that had the best result
seemed to be this one here where we had
no facebook and just plain vanilla so
people don't seem to like the media and
they don't like the customer
testimonials now could be just how I
laid it out but you know from these
examples it just going to show me I want
to keep it simple and the next thing I
might want to do is test the offer so i
can test different office against each
other to see which one works better now
the one thing it did stand out the first
for here it says number one and FB which
means facebook so when you're creating
your different reports you can you call
them whatever you want so i called them
no FB for the ones at the facebook login
and to know FB for the ones that didn't
have the facebook login so these four
were all facebook and these ones did not
give the option sign up for facebook
would just ask your name and email and
what's really surprising for me was the
ones that had the facebook option
converted much more poorly than the ones
that did not have the facebook so if you
look at facebook it was point seven
point six point six point five percent
conversion and no facebook was 1.5 1.3
1.3 1 point 0 so across the board having
the option people to sign up through
facebook really lowers the number of
people who will sign up for newsletter
which is you know i didn't know that so
it was a good test to make sure and now
i'm gonna delete all for these campaigns
and focus on a no facebook option and
trying to get these going better so this
was a new project for me and I didn't
know what to expect with any new project
I'm usually expecting pretty low numbers
and then you test test test test test
until you can boost a response rate so
what I'm probably going to do is
obviously delete these first four with
Facebook and then try to optimize used a
little bit better so you know 1.5% I
best now how do i I'll change the offer
and maybe make this design a little bit
better play around with the colors to
try to get that to two percent or two
and a half percent or three percent and
again that's just a value of testing
most of the hard work was in creating
that report but just by making a few
simple tweeks you can triple the number
of people who respond to your
offer so I hope that helps that's you
know pretty easy to do with in a weber
you may need a little bit of technical
backend to understand how to make it
randomly choose one of these eight
options or one of two options whatever
it is for your website I just wanted to
illustrate the importance of testing and
you know being able to triple your
results is something that I think most
entrepreneurs with that would want to do
for their site so thank you for watching
another video if you guys liked it
please leave a comment below I'd love to
hear what you guys are doing if you have
any questions let me know in the comment
and i always appreciate those thumbs ups
if you want to give them on the videos
so thank you and stay tuned for the next
episode
you